recently. Uh, but I I'm going to tell
you what what made me uh change my mind
about all that. Um, I grew up Christian,
but here's here's here's what made me,
you know, switch my mindset. Um,
>> what switched your what?
>> Why? My my religion.
>> Sound that's not what you said, though.
It sound like you said something else.
What?
>> I said mindset because at first it was
my mindset and then it was my religion.
>> Okay. I thought you said what made you
switch your set.
>> Oh, no. No. I ain't like that.
>> [laughter]
>> Um, all I want to know, sir, man, all I
want to know is how can how can So, do
you believe like the trendy is three
distinct? Like they're not the same
person at all?
>> Yeah. They're not the same person, but
they're the same God. Same being,
different persons.
>> How can How can three distinct persons
with three like their own wills and own
mindsets? They share the same will in
the same person. They share the same
will in the same mind
>> or they're distinct in person because
there's true
>> uh differentiation between them.
>> What's the distinction?
>> So the father is unbegotten, the son is
begotten and the spirit is spirated or
proceeds from the father's substance.
>> Are they so what what I mean like are
they all the father just revealed in
different ways or are they
>> Nope. They're not the father because the
father is the the father is a specific
person of the trinity. The father is the
what you some call I believe the the
monarch right the the source of the
substance the source of the divine
substance
>> and he begets the son eternally so
that's the distinction between the
father and son the father is unbegotten
he begets the son
>> okay
>> and the spirit
>> proceeds forth from the father
>> so these these
>> that's what I've heard all my life
>> but what what about this though
>> so if the father is in heaven and he's
like almighty God, right? And then he
sends his son down, right?
>> Now we all worship his son instead of
the father.
>> No, you honor
>> I know. I know.
>> No, brother. You worship the father and
the son and the spirit. You don't
isolate either of them. Jesus says the
same way that you honor the father, you
honor the son both at the same time. Not
>> right
>> either or.
>> Okay. Um I I hear you. I'm listening.
Like my I'm I'm willing to like the same
with you. I'm willing to change my mind
if I'm convinced.
>> Okay.
>> Um
>> and I'm willing to like even do the
reading. I haven't done as much research
as I probably should. I'm willing to
learn. Um but here's another question I
have. Um [clears throat] okay, so if the
son was sent down and then he was
glorified, right? That's what it says,
right? He was glorified.
>> Why would
>> is there now two gods? Is there the
father and Christ in heaven as God? Like
is there two gods in heaven now?
So this is what the trinity is. The
trinity is one god that exists as three
distinct persons. Okay? So that's why
you can have the son sitting at the
right hand of the father or the son
sending the holy spirit from the father
stuff like that. You see these
interactions between the three persons.
>> Yeah.
>> Because they're distinct in their
personhood but they are just they are
one being. They share those the one
divine essence the one being of God. So,
it's one God up there.
>> I brought this up to people
[clears throat] before I I brought this
up to like some of my Christian friends
and even family members and they all
like threw threw the idea down. What if
like so like even before I changed
religions, I brought this up to them
like what if it was just like the father
and then the father lowered himself
lower than the angels and it was the
father and Jesus. Like it was the
father. The only separation was Jesus's
humanity.
Well, that would be impossible because
Jesus literally says that he's the son
who came down
from the father. So,
>> he still would be the son because he has
no human father.
>> No, he's not. Is no the the son has
always been the son. The father has
always been the father. For the father
to always be the father, you have to
have a son. You have to have a a child,
right? So, because God is unchanging,
the father has eternally been the
father, which means that he eternally
had the son.
Make sense?
>> Okay. I don't know, man. I hear you. I
hear you. I hear you. This I guess like
>> Does it make sense that that God is
unchanging
and
>> Yeah. Yeah. I believe that. And
>> so good. So then if if the father,
[cough] God [clears throat] the Father
is infinite and eternal and has always
been the father.
Well, to be the father, that means you
have to be the father of something,
right? You're not a father unless you
have a child. So if he's eternally and
infinitely the father,
>> that means that he eternally and
infinitely has a son that he begins.
>> What about uh what's this verse? I think
it's uh something 6:4 Deuteronomy 64
where it says something like
>> hero Israel God is one. Yeah.
But how can he be I don't understand
this. Like how can he be
>> It's the same It's the same word
>> if he's three person.
>> It's the same word that says like so it
says uh a man shall leave his mother and
father and cleave to his wife and the
two shall become one flesh.
>> Good point. They're not literally one,
but they're one.
>> There's a compound unity.
>> I've been listening to you for a while,
too. So like I do like I I I want I want
the grace that he offers but I just
don't understand it.
>> Well that's why God says come let us
reason together in Isaiah chapter 1. He
doesn't he doesn't turn away the one who
honestly is seeking and honestly has
questions even honestly has doubts he
just wants you to bring them to him.
Don't abandon him because you are
confused about some things. Don't
abandon him.
>> But
>> bring these doubts, bring these
questions to him and he'll guide you to
places where you'll get these clear
answers.
>> Just got to give them let let God do let
God do God, man.
>> So, like I said, I've been thinking
about this for a while. So, I did a
little research on like uh the Trinity
alone, like where it came from. And you
know it might not be right because I was
using Google and like you know not
necessarily scholarly sources but from
what I was gathering
>> the the three persons one God that
really came from like Catholicism and
Rome after the apostles died
>> it was always they were always preaching
one God.
>> Well the trinity is one God brother.
It's just that God exists
>> even Jesus like
>> they were
>> brother brother this is what the
disciples taught.
>> So it is so it so it all is the God.
>> Yeah. They're all God. The apostles all
taught that the father is God. The son
is God and the holy spirit is god. This
is in the bible bro before any Christian
sect came about. This is in the bible.
This is in the scriptures. This is in
the this is what the prophets taught in
the old testament. And this is what the
apostles taught in the gospel and in
their letters.
Right. But then you go to like the
council of Nicima or whatever it is and
they're trying to debate on what who
Jesus is.
>> And they come up with the fact that he
is in an essence. I'm sorry. Um
>> he like they decided he was one essence
but he wasn't the same as
>> Nope. They decided no. So what's what's
going on um what's going on at the
council of Nika is that there is a
heretic named Aras who is trying to
argue that Jesus is a lesser god than
the father that he does not share the
same substance as the father. And so the
>> bishops of the church, those who were
descendants and followers of the
apostles,
they contended against this heresy and
use the scripture to demonstrate that
Jesus is of the same substance of the
father. He's begotten, not made. He's
not created. He has the same substance,
same being as the father.
So,
>> so also I know another verse when I was
doing this research I came across it
said it said God was manifest in flesh.
That's where so where does I don't see
the separation. Where does this three
person
>> there is no separ there is no
separation. There's just a distinction
there. The distinction is is that the
father and the son and the spirit they
are not the same person. The son is not
the father. The father sends the son.
The son comes and incarnates the spirit.
>> Exactly.
Exactly.
So what the scriptures what what the
what the scriptures show you
>> is that the monotheistic God of Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob exists as three
distinct persons. The father, son, and
holy spirit coexist together, sharing
the same one divine essence as the one
God.
>> Okay.
Okay.
>> That's in the B. That's that's that's
Bible, bro. I know some of this stuff
>> that's Bible.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I just I don't know. It got
a little confusing after a minute cuz I
hear the Muslims they talk about like
you know we'll say you know God is just
one and then y'all say he's three. So
that's what threw me off I guess.
>> Yeah. Well M Muslims believe that God is
one person. Christians believe uh
according to the prophets and the
apostles
saying it's also monotheism. It's not
three. Like it's still
>> it's not it's not three gods. It's one
God. Monotheism is the concept that
there's one God. Mono one theist theo
god.
>> Yeah.
>> That's all it is. So what we have what
the Bible teaches is trinitarian
monotheism.
>> Okay.
>> So so he's just revealing himself in
three different ways. He's not actually
three different peoples.
>> Let me I don't know. I'm trying to be as
clear as I can. other
get get this out of your head that
uh maybe he's just he's just revealing
himself in three different ways or
modes. That's modalism. That's a heresy
called modalism where God just manifests
in different modes or different ways.
But these aren't real.
>> I believe he can do work here.
>> Just just one second. One second, Kai.
One second.
God exists as the scripture says
as three distinct persons.
You have the person of the father. You
have the person of the son. You have the
person of the holy spirit. These three
persons
are distinct from one another in their
personhood. One is unbegotten, that's
the father. One is begotten, that's the
son. One is spirated, that's the holy
spirit.
And they are one in their essence as the
one God. They share the same divine
essence.
Okay.
>> All right. I hear you. I hear you on
that. Can I ask one more question?
>> Go ahead.
>> Um I don't mean to waste your time,
brother, making you repeat yourself. Um
>> that's okay. Sometimes we got to do
that, man. Question is we got to repeat.
It's all right.
So, so it's I I remember I remember
learning that like it says something
where like Jesus was
uh alive before flesh, right? Like he
said before Abraham I I am or something
like that.
>> That's right.
>> So he before he had flesh, he was alive,
right? Who was he before that? Was he
the father or was he just like the
floating spirit? Who was
>> He's the son of God, brother. He's
always the son.
Proverbs 30 says this, "Who is he that
ascends and descends? Who gathers the
winds in his fist? Who uh something
about the waters
it says, what is his name and what is
his son's name?" Surely you know that's
Proverbs.
>> So way before Jesus incarnates and takes
on human flesh, the son is spoken of.
What? Proverbs Proverbs 30 Holy Spirit,
>> brother. You playing with me?
>> No, no, no, no. I promise I'm not. Do
you believe Jesus is the Holy Spirit?
>> I think you're playing with me. I I
think I think you're playing with me.
>> But no, this is a verse in the Bible.
This is a verse in the Bible that says,
"Jesus said, I will not leave you
comfortless. I will come to you."
>> I got you. So, do do me this favor,
brother. This is on YouTube. Go ahead
and watch this back. Listen to what I'm
saying and I promise you, you'll have
the answer to your question and the
things I already said. Okay. I'm going
let somebody else up in the meantime.
All right.
>> All right. My bad. I might be lacking
understanding. My fault.
>> All right. God bless you, bro.
>> Y
[clears throat]
Hello, IAS.
>> What's what's up my brother? How are
you?
>> Pretty good. Pretty good. Are you a
Muslim?
>> Yeah, I'm a Muslim.
>> Ah,
alhamdulillah. Yes.
>> That's nice.
>> Thanks. So, why should I convert to
Islam? So you want to you you want to
convert to Islam?
>> I don't want to.
But why should I? I'm asking.
>> Sure.
>> I'm asking why I should.
>> Okay. Well, I think that uh if you look
at the general picture, there's a man
coming in the desert coming with the
descriptions of the natural world that
people didn't know at the time. He's
coming with prophecies that seem to be
true. And also, he can't be from Satan.
It's pretty obvious he's from God. You
know
>> what's what makes it obvious that he's
from God?
>> Uh because he's coming with supernatural
events and he can't be from Satan. If
you look in Matthew, it says Matthew 12,
it says that somebody who speaks against
Satan can't be from Satan. Jesus says
that.
>> No, it doesn't.
>> And Muhammad is speaking against Satan.
The Quran is speaking against Satan. So,
he can't be from Satan. So, he has to be
from another
>> It doesn't It doesn't It doesn't say
that. It doesn't say that.
>> It does say that.
>> Um, where does Jesus say that Satan's
name is Eliss?
>> But you know the word Shayan?
>> Yeah. Where does where does Jesus say
that Satan's name is?
>> But you know that we have the word in
the Quran. We say
I seek refu refuge with God from Satan.
It's the same word.
And in Matthew 12, he says, "A house
divided of itself cannot stand if Satan
drives.
[snorts]
Yo,
>> how you doing?" Yo.
Why is my name Ilas? What the heck?
>> It's It's glitching, man. What's your
name?
>> Sorry. Sorry. How are you? My name is
Adam. I don't know why it says Ilas on
that.
>> Adam. Nice to meet you, Adam.
>> Yeah, man. Um,
what was I going to say, broki? Liiano
is out here. He's about to be live in a
few minutes, man. You seen that? I think
he's calling out or something. I don't
know.
>> Why isn't he here,
>> bro? To be honest with you, man, I
I don't have that answer, man. I just
I'm kind of new to this. Like people
people saying they're running and stuff
like that. I'm like, yo, people saying
Liiano is running. I'm just confused.
I'm just trying to get me. I'm just new
to this. Like, what's happening? Can you
fill me in on that?
>> Well, I'm live. He can come and join the
live anytime.
>> Yeah, man. Why is he not doing that,
though?
>> That's a good question. Ask him.
I swear I seen something about like you
want
>> I joined I joined his live. He won't
join mine though. I don't know why he
won't come here.
>> Bro, I was watching your live on
YouTube. Yeah. And when you started up,
whoever you had this one guy come and um
he brought like a good point, man. He
kind of like kind of dropped the guy and
moved on to the next guy. Like you know
>> what what point do you think it was
good?
like uh you asked him like, "Oh, does
Allah in the Quran say like quote
someone and not and you know that
remember that that you dropped them?"
>> Yeah. What what do you think what what
point do you think he made that was good
that that solved the problem?
>> I mean he basically backed you into a
corner where you had to like say like
Allah is saying he has his own Allah or
something like that and oh I just proved
Allah isn't one or something like that.
I'm like yeah
>> that's me silly. That's me being backed
into a corner by reading what Allah
says.
>> Yeah, man. That's you being backed into
a corner. You're acting a bit silly,
brok I'm new to this. You get me? I'm
just I heard good things about you.
[clears throat] Good things about that.
>> I mean, when I seen that, I was kind of
like, yo,
>> that So, let's see. Let's Let's see if
we can uh see if this is a good a good
point here. All right. So, it's chapter
>> and it was like around like the 16th
verse or whatever.
>> Yeah. I just I just I just found it like
surprising that like that's the
conclusion you drew from from reading
those verses that
Allah, you know.
>> Let's see who who's the speaker of the
Quran whose words are they?
>> Come on, man. Don't be silly, broki.
>> Who is it?
>> Allah.
>> Okay.
>> Allah. So you're saying that it's silly
of me to read the Quran
>> knowing that every every word belongs to
Allah unless he's quoting someone in the
context it didn't say he was quoting
anyone but we saw when he began to quote
somebody he started quoting the
disbelievers he said they say
>> and then he begins to quote them
>> so but here though Allah speaking like
for example it says uh
>> [clears throat]
>> Let's see where is it at. Where's the
verse? It says
it says, "And they believed. So we gave
them enjoinment for a time and we sent
him to a hundred thousand or more."
That's that's all I speaking, right?
Talking about what he did. He sent
people and all this kind of stuff,
right?
>> Huh?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay.
And then he goes on and continues, "Or
did we create the angels as females
while they were witnesses?" That's Allah
speaking, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Allah creates the
angels.
>> Okay. So Allah continuing to speak all
the way down here. He could just He's
just talking and talking and talking. He
keeps talking and he says, "Exalted is
Allah above what they describe except
the chosen servants of Allah. So indeed
you and whatever you worship you cannot
tempt away from him except he who is to
uh burn in the fail fire. There is not
any among us any except that he has
known has a known position and indeed we
are those who line up and indeed we are
those who exalt Allah. So Allah speaking
says that he exalts Allah and lines up
for him.
>> Indeed, we are those who exalt Allah.
>> Yeah, man. And you drew the conclusion
that that's Allah saying he exalts
>> because every word is Allah's word.
[sighs]
>> Yeah, man. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, that's
that's cool, bro. That's cool. That's
your own uh interpretation. You're
you're you're uh entitled to that, you
know. I just
>> I mean, I'm just I'm just reading it,
brother. I'm not. See, you told me not
to be silly. I'm not being silly. I'm
just reading.
>> It's not really just It's not really
just about reading, bro. It's You have
to understand the text. You got
>> I am. I'm understanding that Allah
exalts Allah and and lines up for him.
>> All right. All right. All right. Okay.
So, what's this Liiano thing though?
Like, are you guys going to go at it or
like is he running or are you running?
Like, who's running? G.
>> All right. We'll see. Thanks for coming
up, man. All right. Let's see. Somebody
named Corey wants to come up. Corey
Crawford.
[gasps]
>> Corey, what's up, man? They they've been
telling me to let you up, man. Why Why
are they telling me to let you up?
>> What's up, brother? How you doing?
>> Pretty good. How are you?
>> I'm good, man. Yeah, I'm I'm Muslim, but
it's time to come back.
Time to come back where
>> Christianity.
I was a Christian man. And what it was,
I don't know what led me, but I feel
like maybe I was misled.
And it's not likely of me to be that
type of person to be misled. And I know
I said those little declarations of
faith, but I knew that I had to come
back and get say, "It ain't right to me,
brother." You know what I mean? It ain't
right.
>> I don't feel I don't feel well, nor do
it.
>> You kind of cut out there. Say that
again.
>> I said it don't feel right to me and it
don't sit right to me.
[snorts]
>> I see. So
you uh you are convicted to come back to
Christ to denounce Islam
and all that good stuff. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> Okay, man. I mean, if you're if you're
serious,
uh [clears throat] you know, I'll just
ask you some simple questions, bro. Just
just simply because the Bible says that
if you confess with your mouth mouth and
believe in your heart that Jesus Christ
is your Lord and that God raised him
from the dead that you shall be saved
and um that [clears throat] this has to
be a genuine this is why it says it's
from the heart. It's a genuine faith.
It's a genuine belief, right? It's not
just something that you're just saying,
but it's a conviction that you truly
have. It's a heart change. You
understand what I'm saying?
>> Oh, yeah. I understand this with
sincerity.
>> Yeah. So, uh just I'll just ask you
straight up, man. Do you you you
denounce Islam? You renounce Islam as a
false religion?
>> Yes.
>> You renounce uh Muhammad as a false
prophet, brother?
>> Yes.
>> Praise God. And do you believe that
Jesus is your Lord and Savior?
>> I do. And you believe that Jesus Christ
rose again from the dead, was punished
for your sins, rose again from the dead.
You believe this?
>> Yes.
>> Amen, brother. With that being said,
man, I just say welcome. Welcome home.
[laughter]
Welcome home, man.
>> Good to be home.
>> Welcome home.
>> Wow. How How long?
>> No, I said
>> Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Go ahead. No, I'm good. I cut off. No, I
was I was just going to ask you how long
were you Muslim and then [clears throat]
and then what changed?
>> Brother, I a I ain't even I ain't even
gonna lie to you, man. Only like a month
and a half.
>> You It was a only about a month and a
half.
>> Hey,
man. Look, it's it's better than years
in my perspective.
>> I agree, bro. The the quicker the
better. The quicker the better. You
>> Yeah.
You got out of there faster than fast
enough for you know you not to be
completely brainwashed by the stupidity.
>> Well in Oops.
>> Yeah. You know what it was? I thought of
my brother man cuz I lost my brother
some years back and he followed God and
he followed Christ.
>> And you know I was I was on the panel
you was on today too when you was on
with the my Muslim cousin.
>> Oh you was in there. [laughter]
Yeah, I was in there and I was listening
to you. But I've been I've been watching
you, brother. I've been watching you and
I love what you do and it's a beautiful
thing that you do.
>> Praise God.
>> I see you be you be going all around all
around the way. New York, Speakers
Corner out there in the UK. It's a
beautiful thing and you know, it just
made me realize that this isn't this
isn't the path that my feet were meant
to be. You know what I mean?
>> Yeah. 100%, bro.
>> Guys, this is what it's about, man. this
is this is why we do this. Now, I I'
I've never spoken to you. Like, we we've
never spoken. I've never, you know, like
gave the gospel to you or showed you why
Islam was false. Like, personally, I
never But you said you've been listening
that guys, this is why we do this, man.
We do this because God is reaching
people even that we do not talk to
directly. The God is working on the
hearts of the listeners. God is working
on people's hearts. He was he converted
to Islam and a month and a half later he
said, "Nope, this ain't it." That's
deep, Corey. [laughter]
>> Yeah. I mean, hey, we we all go through
things, man. Sometimes it's not the best
of ways and it's sometimes our life is
kind of crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, granted, everybody has their own
experiences
>> and you know, sometimes people will get
thrown off and put into a different
path, but you know,
>> Yeah. God God knows what God knows and
he'll make it meant for you to come on
back home.
>> Amen.
>> And I seen the I seen the comments when
they said uh the prodical son. I I
recall it.
>> Yeah.
>> I recall it. I And it ain't never left
me, man. It's just
>> I can't I can't recall nor can I even
understand why it was.
>> But we're here now and I'm
>> We're here now, man. God brought you
back open arms. You went away. You
strayed away. Brought you right back.
And he accepted you, man. Happily. The
angels rejoice. The father is rejoicing.
The son, the spirit rejoice. We all
believers were rejoicing now, bro. You
should see the comment section on
YouTube. They're going crazy, man. We
love you. Um, I just want to I just want
to give you some encouragement, man, cuz
this Tik Tok is very dangerous. It's a
very dangerous world. a lot of
falsehoods out there, a lot of things
that can uh seem convincing, you know,
but but it's opposed to the truth, which
is exactly how Satan works. That's how
the serpent works. He brings things that
are appeasing and seem convincing with a
little bit of it seems like there's a
little bit of truth. Uh but always seek
God, man. Always seek the Lord. Always
seek him. Do not let go of him again. Do
not abandon him. Hold tightly to him.
Even in confusion or whatever, run to
him. Don't run away from him. Okay.
>> I I recall that one. Therefore, take no
thought, saying, "What should we eat?
What should we drink? Whether all we be
clothed, for all these things the
Gentiles seek, you heavenly Father, in
need of all these things."
>> That's right.
>> But seek ye first the kingdom of God and
his righteousness, and all things should
be added unto you.
>> It's still with me.
>> That's right. It's still in you, man.
[laughter]
>> It's still It's still with him. But, you
know, we we we go to stray, man.
Sometimes we go astray just to go back
to where we're meant to be.
>> Yeah, man. Thank God for his grace, man.
Thank God for his grace cuz he's willing
to take us after we done walked off and
abandoned. He's willing to reel us right
back in. Praise God for you. I praise
God. Thank you for coming up, man. Uh
and and you know, giving your life,
being brave enough and courageous enough
to give your life to the Lord again.
That that that's humble. It's humbling.
It's
>> it's inspiring. It's encouraging.
Appreciate you, man. Stay connected.
Okay. There's a bunch there's a bunch of
us that do this. Stay connected, man.
Um, we got your back. You ain't You
ain't by yourself out here, okay?
[snorts]
>> I already know it. Hey, and keep on
doing what you're doing, brother.
Everybody looking at you, brother.
You're an example to a lot of people.
So, keep on shining, brother.
>> Praise God. Praise God. All right. Thank
you for coming up, man. After you, man.
I'm ending the live now. I got to end it
on this note. We done, y'all.
>> No, you ain't. No, you ain't got to lie.
You ain't got to do all that.
>> No, man. We We already at three hours,
man. I I got to end it off with this.
[laughter]
This the best way.
>> Yeah. What's that?
>> Shoot. Shoot.
>> Whichever way you see fit.
>> Praise God. All right. Thanks for coming
up, man. I appreciate you, man. God
bless you, bro. Love you, brother.
>> God bless you, brother. Be easy. Love
you, too, brother.
>> Yes, sir. Awesome stuff, guys. Wow. Hey,
what what a way to cap off the live
stream. Yeah, what a way to cap off the
live stream. We got done. Uh for the
people that are here, Muslim defender,
uh Abdur Rahman,
Tyler, I see you guys. Come on. Well,
come Friday, we'll be doing we'll be
doing Islam on Friday. Uh Wednesday,
guys, we'll be taking on on Hebrew
Israelites. He uh Wednesday, we will be
taking on Hebrew Israelites. I'll have
Faithful to God with me and I'll have
Vocab Malone with me. If you guys don't
know those brothers, you going to know
them Wednesday. These dudes are beasts.
Bo is the general. Faithful to God.
Tough soldier man. We're going to be
here live Wednesday, same time, 2:00
p.m. Pacific time, 5:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time, dealing with Hebrew
Israelites. So, if you are a Hebrew
Israelite and you're in the chat, you're
a Hebrew Israelite. You believe we don't
got to keep uh we you believe that we're
still bound to the law. You believe that
only Israelites can be saved. You are
more than welcome. I mean, you deny the
deity of Christ. You're more than
welcome to come on Wednesday, 5:00 p.
p.m. Eastern Standard Time. We'll be
live with Vocat Malone. I know he's your
I know he's your uh your boogeyman. And
we're gonna have Faithful to God here.
Another boogeyman of y'all. But don't
worry, I I'll I'll make sure I tame
them. They they'll be all right. You'll
be good. All right, come on Wednesday.
Hebrew Israelites, we're calling y'all
out. With that being said, y'all, man, I
love you guys. We doing we doing the
Lord's work, man. It's kingdom work at
the end of the day. Doesn't matter
what's going on. When there's somebody
that is ready to give their life to
Christ, I don't care what topic I'm
doing. [snorts] I don't care who I'm
talking to in the in the midst of it. We
shutting down everything to get this
soul so that they confess. they can
confess before witnesses that Jesus is
Lord and how he saved them. So man,
praise God for Corey for the for the
courage to come up uh humb being humble
enough to come up admit he was wrong and
straight and how God brought him back.
That's man
pride was gone. His pride was gone. He's
completely humble. Beautiful. This is
kingdom work. This is why we do what we
do, y'all. This is what God logic is all
about. All right. So, with that being
said, uh I love you guys, man. Um
Inspiring just went live. Inspiring
Philosophy. All right. Inspire Inspiring
Philosophy just went live. I think Word
Word and I might be live later. I'm not
sure, but Word and I might be live
later. Um but yeah, y'all got good
content, you know, around the clock.
Good Christian content around the clock.
So, go ahead, join Inspiring Philosophy.
If you just started live, go ahead and
head on over there. Go support the
brother. Make sure y'all hit that like
button. I appreciate everybody that
dropped the super stickers. We got
sister saying, "Stay in your Bible,
brother." From Zoe. Um, [clears throat]
let's see here. We got Nathaniel saying,
"Amen. Thank you for for what you do,
Avery." Amen to that. John saying, "Pray
that God leads Corey to a good church
and that he gets baptized if he hasn't
been." Amen. Amen. Amen. Amen. And we
got uh Lion Famous says, Lion Famous,
sorry. Lion Famous says, "Christ wins
another soul, the devil loses a fellow
prisoner in eternity." That's right.
That's right. We got uh truth through
scripture says, "Even in the Quran 112:4
[clears throat]
explains that there's nothing comparable
to God." Why can't Muslims take that
into consideration when viewing the
triune God? Why is it automatically
impossible? Because they're Muslim, man.
That that's just what it is. It's
because they're Muslim. No logic to it,
no true reasoning. It's because they're
Muslim. Okay, I got to get going though.
I love you guys, man. Thank you
everybody for the super chats. Thank you
to everyone joining the Patreon, giving
to the uh to [clears throat] the
donation link. I really appreciate you
guys. We're able to do a lot of big
stuff because of your support. So, keep
it up. Keep praying for us. Keep praying
for the ministry. Pray for me and my
wife. And uh we'll see you guys next
time. All right. Y'all know what to do.
Always ask the Muslim the man when you
get a chance.
[screaming]